welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and we just got
our first sneak peek look at ironheart's
new villain according to leaked set
photos anthony ramos is set to stars the
mcu's parker robbins aka the hood
interestingly the hood and iron heart
don't run in the same super circles in
the comics so i'm personally really
excited to see how marvel incorporates
his character into riri's story today
i'm going to explain who the hood is and
how he may appear in the upcoming
ironheart tv series parker robbins was
first introduced in 2002's the hood
blood from stone six issue miniseries
written by brian k vaughn and kyle hopps
these are from marvel's explicit max
comics so i gotta warn you that there's
a lot of harmful slurs in there that
definitely do not fly in the year of our
lord 2022 so read with caution in this
run parker is a high school dropout
whose mother lives in an assisted care
facility due to dementia he also has a
pregnant girlfriend who he cheats on
with sex workers frequently parker lies
to both of them about the shady ways he
makes his money unable to afford a
better hospital for his mother he
decides to take his cousin up on a
burglary job that'll pay handsomely if
they can pull it off parker and john
break into a locked facility in the dead
of night hoping to steal a major
incoming shipment instead the two are
confronted with a horrific demon and a
red cape parker shoots and seemingly
kills the demon before stealing his
cloak in black boots after slipping into
the boots to escape a gang of muggers he
discovers that his new kicks allow him
to levitate and shortly after learns
that he can turn invisible inside his
cape while holding his breath after
accidentally killing a cop parker
robbins lands on the fbi's most wanted
list where he's first dubbed the hood
after being attacked by two fake aim
agents the hood activates the demon that
is now within him he discovers that he
can a speak demon and b shoot lightning
bolts out of his fingies like palpatine
from hell later on the hood can even
transform robins into a full-blown demon
during the events of civil war in the
comics he creates his own super
organized crime syndicate and wilson
fist aka kingpin's absence often duking
it out with the new avengers in new
avengers number 46 set during the skrull
invasion parker finally learns that the
power behind his cape is dormammu ruler
of the dark dimension during the events
of the dark rain norman osborne recruits
the hood in his crime syndicate to
protect osborne's avengers from the new
avengers attacks and parker uses
dormammu's powers to resurrect a team of
dead villains to help stop the punisher
from killing osborne dormammu later
empowers the hood with enough magic to
hunt down doctor strange and kill him
allowing him to become the next sorcerer
supreme parker fails to capture strange
but i'm personally fascinated by
parker's allegiance to dormammu she-hulk
season is upon us is it okay to say
she-hulk she's in i'm just gonna say it
she-hulk she's in
if you're green with envy for marvel's
newest attorney epic hero shop.com has
you covered latest obsession number 19
lady justice is available in the shop
for a limited time and if that's not
enough for you epic hero shop's got a
girl boss shirt in a font that maybe
fans of she-hulk will recognize but i
think that what we all love about
she-hulk isn't just the ability to
boldly forge novel legal precedents in
the name of justice or her perfect green
skin it's that in a lot of ways she's
the personification of justice itself
that's what the superhuman law division
t is all about justice is jacked these
designs would be rad if they were on
posters but you get to wear them yes and
trust me epic hero shop stuff is comfy
as hell regular rotation for sure this
is absolutely the best way to support
the channel and wearing the merch is the
best way to spot fans in the wild so
make sure to wear it to avengers campus
conventions and opening weekend also be
sure to tag epic hero shop and use
real epic hero to get featured on their
page get everything you need to be the
stylish nerd you know you are at
epicheroshop.com
tis the season as the hood's powers are
connected to interdimensional mystic
arts in the comics i think it could be
really interesting to see him go up
against iron hearts tech in the upcoming
series and after seeing dominique thorne
and shuri's lab in the wakanda forever
trailer we now know that she has access
to some of the most cutting-edge tech in
the entire world in the comics she
attends mit at only 15 years old
connects with tony stark and ends up
building her own iron heart suit so
skipping straight to shuri's lab is a
major upgrade in my opinion mit is great
don't get me wrong they just don't have
cool giant battle rhinos roaming around
their campus and this lab does as she
comes into her own as iron heart it'll
be really cool to actually see her fight
head to head with a magic wielder with
her souped up tech although tony stark
got in plenty of wizard jabs about
doctor strange and tussled with the
infinity stones before he died his solo
films never really focused on battling
the mystic arts i'm stoked to see riri
williams become her own unique hero
outside of tony's immediate influence
facing a variety of opponents and
accessing new tech that tony never got
the chance to and that's where the hood
might come in if riri has access to
vibranium wakandan tech or even some of
the pymtek we've seen pop up so far in
phase four parker robbins and his
organized crime ring might want to get
their hands on it i have a feeling the
hood won't be the one pulling the
strings at first when he debuts because
the escalation of robin's ambitions is
what makes the character so interesting
on the page like i mentioned a second
ago the hood did work as a hired gun in
several of his early comics sent to hunt
down heroes on behalf of other bigger
villains although i know it's highly
unlikely that norman osborne is going to
randomly pop up in ironheart as the big
bad behind the hood's crimes i do think
that we could see him working with
another baddie that we've suspected will
fill aspects of osborne shoes in the mcu
kingpin i mean we all know he's totally
not dead right i could definitely see
fisk and robin's linking up just two mob
boys making life a live in hell for
street level superheroes instead of
filling in the void of kingpin's absence
in new york with his own crime syndicate
the hood's future trajectory in the mcu
could feature him as one of his proteges
like echo comic book parker robin's
father has ties to fisk now that maya
has betrayed him kingpin might be
dipping into other loyalties to recruit
robins putting a criminal sorcerer on
his payroll is the perfect way to level
up the playing field with meddlesome
heroes if this is the case the hood
might be the connective tissue that
links ironheart to other disney plus
stories alternatively parker could
simply be responsible for riri's tragic
past in the comics riri's stepfather and
her best friend natalie were killed in a
drive-by shooting incident instead of
having parker accidentally kill police
officer the mcu could make the hood iron
heart's loved one's killer giving riri
all the more re-reasons to take this
villain out regardless of who the hood
is or isn't working with his powers
still come back down to the magic of his
boots and cape and i can't wait to see
iron heart kick his mystic ass with her
cool tech follow me on instagram and
twitter at whitney puppy follow new
rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you